hey guys I'm Abbi short welcome to
Abby's kitchen so last time you saw me
sitting in this chair I was getting
emotional as I was getting ready for my
first Mother's Day it was pre baby and
now of course I'm on the other side
I'm almost seven weeks postpartum so
that's really exciting and I mean this
journey is being so interesting and
overwhelming and one of the big things
that I think has really surprised me is
how absolutely amazingly difficult the
whole breastfeeding thing actually is I
think that we tend to position
breastfeeding as being some super
natural innate thing that women are just
supposed to be able to get but I have
found that it is so far from natural or
innate in fact it's probably being one
of the hardest things I've ever done in
my life so I think all moms have their
own struggle when it comes to
breastfeeding for us there were a number
of things that were stacked against us
one my baby came out and was super
congested so the LC or the lactation
consultant right away said oh my gosh
that baby's not gonna want to eat
because they are just so clogged up he
literally sounded like an English
Bulldog that's how bad it was number two
I had PCOS and a postpartum hemorrhage
both of those things apparently can
delay and reduce breast milk supply so
that was a challenge for sure and then
number three my little one had both a
lip and a tongue type and if you're not
familiar what that is you're like well
what the heck does that mean basically
stick your finger in your mouth
underneath your tongue you'll feel a
little piece of skin there that's
connecting your tongue to the bottom of
your mouth
well my babies is really really tight or
at least it was so we had to have that
kind of cut out or removed in order for
him to be able to move his tongue up and
down which is a really important
movement during breastfeeding so I
basically had both a issue of reduced
supply and also
just a really bad latch so breastfeeding
was pretty much impossible it was
painful I wasn't able to have enough
milk to feed my very very very hungry
hippo baby and it was just absolutely
exhausting I mean as a registered
dietician I we've been all trained to
believe that fed is best and I
wholeheartedly do believe it you know if
you were to ask me or if I was speaking
to another mom I would say oh my gosh
you've got to do whatever you can to
make sure that your baby is being fed
enough and and that means supplementing
and that's great you know but when it
happened to me I felt so defeated I felt
like my body let me down and then I was
letting down my baby if I became
completely obsessed and the first night
I remember we we supplemented quite a
lot and and every night after that it
you know the ratio started to to go down
and down it down but it for me it was
still just so so disheartening that even
an ounce of formula had to go into my
baby because I felt like my body should
be able to do this all you know I
shouldn't be having these problems and
that I should be able to provide this
one thing for my baby and and I just
felt like I was inadequate
I feel like you know there's there's two
things happening here
one is the delivery of breast milk
itself and that's being seen as you know
superior form of nourishment for our
babies and then two is the idea of
actually breastfeeding and that that's
posted ly able to kind of create a
really important bond between mom and
baby and I was feeling at both of those
I felt like I wasn't able to give my
child exclusively breast milk I was
pumping around the clock like literally
every hour on the hour I was attached to
that pump in order to get some breast
milk to feed my child but that meant I
would have to bottle feed because we had
such a bad latch that I just wasn't able
to get him on the breast so I just
remember you know the first few times we
left the house and of course with
bottles in tow I was feeding my child
with a bottle even though it was Ashley
breast milk I felt like every single
other mom around me was judging me was
judging me for not putting that baby on
the breast because we we do talk about
it all the time and I can't tell you how
many random strangers that I saw me on
the street or people who I barely know
or friends or family who would say are
you breastfeeding they seems like
everybody asked me you know aside from
how are you doing and what's-his-name
the leg the next question was always are
you breastfeeding and I you know before
I gave I gave birth that would have been
a question I never even thought about
but in that moment I felt so anxious and
ashamed and guilty that no I wasn't
breastfeeding
and and you know I was made to feel
really bad about that so looking back at
you know those first two days especially
now after having spoken to so many of my
friends and colleagues who had similar
issues I'm starting to realize that you
know we're all in this together and and
we're all just trying to do the best
that we can and we don't need to feel
like a failure and supplementing even
exclusively feel like feeding formula is
absolutely okay because bed ultimately
is best we want our babies to be
nourished regardless of what that fuel
may be whether it's breast milk or
formula or a combination of both and the
other really important thing is that you
know it's not just about what's best for
the baby but also what's kind of best
for mom - what's best for mom sanity I
know a lot of women who've told me that
by the time that they finally kind of
gave up on breastfeeding and allowed
themselves to have that break they felt
like their whole world opened up that
they they were just able to get out more
they were able to be full feel more
comfortable they had a better
relationship with their partner they had
a better relationship with their baby
because they weren't stressing all day
and all night
about making sure that every single
little drop of fuel that went to their
baby was from their breast and it's a
really hard place to get to but I'm I'm
starting to feel like a lot more at ease
just being good enough with with you
know the hand I be dealt
so I got so much feedback after I
started to open up about my own
struggles with breastfeeding and I think
before I gave birth you know the only
role models I really had were my own mom
who I knew breastfed both my sister and
I and a handful my friends who had kids
and you know I would watch my friends
just so effortlessly put that baby on
their boob and go about their own kind
of conversation they didn't pump they
didn't have to bottle-feed they didn't
have to supplement they don't have to do
any of these things that I felt like I
was like struggling and failing because
I had to do so after reaching out and
and all of you guys at home by blogging
about this on Abbey's kitchen and seeing
the the crazy amount of feedback I got
from so many of you moms who had similar
struggles I just felt so much more
comfortable knowing that you know it's
okay it's okay to to not be perfect it's
okay that this is going to be maybe a
long long journey it's okay that I just
don't innately get this and baby and I
are latched on no problem
no supplementing right from the get-go
and I was really surprised I mean I was
surprised that so many of us are
struggling in silence when you know this
not a good thing seems to be something
that's talked about quite a lot I'm
surprised that I I never really got this
sentiment from from the circles that I
meant it's like nobody wants to talk
about the fact that they feel and
Hateley like they're failing their
infant when reality is we're all just
doing the best we can so as a dietitian
my inclination was to look at the food
what foods can I eat in order to
increase my milk supply and there are so
many blog posts out there if you
searched the internet on a lot of the
mommy blogs and all of them state a very
specific list of foods that you want to
eat in order to increase your milk
supply so things like oatmeal and fennel
and fenugreek and brewers yeast and
asparagus apricots almonds flaxseed
barley there's a lot of these foods that
that people talk about that apparently
increase your supply having said that
when I actually looked at the literature
I found that there's just not a lot of
studies out there that have been done to
prove that these foods actually are
correlated with a boost in milk supply
that doesn't mean that they don't we
just don't really know for sure but
having said that I would say that ate
these foods are really tasty anyways and
B these foods are really nutritious for
you they're nutrient dense and when
you're breastfeeding or or nursing your
nutrient needs are through the roof as
high as a thousand extra calories above
your baseline so including a lot of
these foods in your diet is a really
good easy way to ensure that you're
getting the nutrition that you actually
need in order to support your baby and I
can tell you from my own experience the
days that I eat more and I really kind
of like have to think about eating
enough and making sure that I'm not so
busy that I forget to have lunch or
forget to have breakfast those are the
days where I get the most milk and that
is evidence of that for me at least
but I think the most important thing
that I've learned through this whole
breastfeeding experience is to be kind
to myself and you know so many other
moms out there are experiencing the
exact same thing or very similar
challenges so if we reach out and talk
to one another about it and support one
another you know we feel so much better
so much more empowered and so much more
at ease knowing that you know we're just
doing the best we can at this whole mom
thing and that is good enough so guys
thank you so much for watching this
video if you enjoyed it be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below if you feel comfortable telling me
a little bit about some of your
experiences with breastfeeding was easy
for you was it a challenge what did you
find actually helped you with your
supply and of course subscribe to the
channel I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]
you